Prof: We talked the last
time--
I talked a little about this
whole issue of the imagination
that Dante places,
along with a definition of
love, and the--
and love is the power that
governs,
that shapes the moral world of
Purgatory.
Last time we talked about these
two fossae of Canto XVII,
the two fossae of the center;
it really makes the center kind
of ellipses, as it were,
between imagination and love.
Love is attached to the--it's
joined to a theory of free will,
because it's by choice--because
of our choices that we can be
held accountable for the actions
that we engage in:
loving wrong objects,
loving too much or loving too
little.
Some of the problems,
I think, stem from a certain
misunderstanding about the
imagination.
That Dante should place the
imagination at the center of the
poem should really not surprise
you.
He's a poet and he thinks that
imagination is indeed the path
that he has to take in order to
come to any form of knowledge.
It's only through the
imagination it's not--
that does not exclude
rationality, but that's the
discourse of philosophers,
the discourse of theologians if
you wish,
but he places the imagination
as his way.
And then from that point of
view, he can even challenge some
ideas of the superiority,
let's say, of rational argument
over the imagination.
The imagination is the weapon
of the poet.
How--with what kind of
attributes does he invest the
imagination?
It's tied to memory.
The Canto XVII begins with an
apostrophe to the reader's
memory.
It appears as,
in the feminine,
imaginativa,
the--in the--Dante's silencing
the term vis.
It has a sort of force,
imagination,
it's moved by something else.
Dante does not decide whether
it's the heaven or the stars or
comes from inside us,
but he has a particular power,
a strange power.
It comes like a thief in the
night,
it robs us of any degree of
consciousness about the world
outside of us and,
just as memory dislodges--the
description of memory at the
beginning of Canto XVII,
it's a memory that has an
incredible memory as a form of
the imagination,
as you know.
Memory and the imagination are
connected.
It's a form of the imagination,
but it's a memory that has the
power to move up and down,
the text evokes the Alpine
heights and the depth of the
mole.
It talks about a form of
blindness and yet it creates
vision.
Memory is a figure of time and
then the whole passage is
described in terms of space,
as if imagination had the power
to dislocate us from where we
think that we are.
This is the point,
and it's not an unusual point
for Dante to make,
since this is the poetry of
exile, the poetry of a man who
thinks that he's a stranger
while living on earth.
A man, without a sense,
a clear sense of where his home
may be,
he is--this is the poetry
rooted in the consciousness of
homelessness,
so the imagination is an
extension,
an internalized version of this
sense of homelessness.
It has a power and that power
that doesn't seem to be able to
be--
a power that cannot quite be
contained or coerced within
definite parameters of conduct.
In fact, this insistence on the
imagination,
I'm really recapitulating the
things that maybe I thought I
said and probably I didn't say
last time,
between, on the one hand,
the sin of wrath,
which is a form of madness.
That is to say,
a sin that eclipses the powers
of reason, that's anger,
and on the other hand,
this discourse on love.
This is really what I was
saying.
Dante understands that there is
an imagination which cannot
quite be held in check,
and yet the whole point of the
poem I'm talking--
whenever I'm talking about the
poem,
I point out some seemingly
insignificant details like,
oh look this is a symmetry here
between Canto VI of
Inferno,
Canto VI of Purgatorio,
or whatever,
to indicate that it is a poem
built with a precise principle
of order in mind.
Not only it has order in its
technical execution,
it has order also as a moral
problem.
It's all about ordering the
appetites, ordering the will.
But at the same time along side
with it,
and this is the complexity and
the beauty of Dante's text,
this is another argument that
almost questions,
makes us--forces us into
thinking that there are some
elements that seem to be left
out of this fabric of order that
Dante has woven,
or if you like,
the metaphor has built--
the architecture that he has
built.
Let' see how this argument
really continues.
That's not the end of the story.
This is just a stage in his
movement of self-knowledge and
knowledge of the world.
In fact, Canto XVIII,
we're now moving into a
different moral realm,
it's a moral realm where we
actually know we are moving
toward a so-called,
what Dante and medieval
theorists of vices call
acedia.
Acedia is a Latin term,
which in English we can
describe--
we'll describe as a sort of
despondency,
as a sort of indecisiveness,
sluggishness,
sloth.
That's it, that's the--if you
are interested in knowing more
about what the Middle Ages
thought about this,
this scholar Wenzel wrote a
book called,
Acedia,
exactly about the--both in
English medieval literature,
Dante and other issues.
What more precisely--how can we
go on understanding this
question of acedia?
It's in a sense the parody or
the inversion of contemplation.
It's tied to a sense of loss of
the outside world.
Acedia describes the
condition of the mind that has
found itself indifferent to the
object of desire.
It really is a crisis of desire.
One finds objects that--the
sloth, the sluggishness,
the indecisiveness of the mind.
It is as if the objects of
desire were--had lost their
consistency, their
attractiveness,
their luster.
You just don't care.
It's the problem,
the so-called noonday devil,
the temptation of the monks,
that's why I call it a parody
of contemplation.
It's the temptation that the
monks experienced in their
cloisters when they sort of find
that the whole idea of turning
their minds to the divine is no
longer,
or provisionally perhaps,
is not appealing.
It's the loss of appeal of
anything outside of oneself and
indicates a kind of both
intellectual and dreamy sort of
condition and that's really what
I want to talk about now.
Canto XVIII is the most
intellectual of cantos in
Purgatory.
Dante faces a theoretical issue.
He's talking to Virgil,
and these theoretical issues of
Canto XVIII flow out of the
problems that we have had in
discussing Canto XVII.
As you know,
we are talking about
imagination and love,
and there is an imagination
that somehow is vagabond.
It's a thief,
breaks out of any particular
confines;
it dislodges us.
It takes the ground out of our
own certainties about the way we
see the world.
Remember that the image with
which Canto XVII starts,
Dante places us in a world
which is at the twilight.
There's no real light.
It's all foggy,
and then all of a sudden,
we do see something,
and it's unclear whether we see
something because of the light
that comes from within us.
Memories, for instance,
that's a light we carry within
us, confused,
as they may be,
or some other kind of conscious
intuition.
That's really the discourse of
the imagination and that
dislodged some of us here.
That made it a little difficult
to try to get a hold of--grasp.
Dante has the same problem in
Canto XVIII.
Canto XVIII begins with a
question that he asks of Virgil.
You are talking about love,
you are talking about this
inclination, the whole theory of
love in Canto XVII.
He says, "Master,
my sight,"
this is Canto XVIII the very
beginning,
"is so quickened in thy
light that I discern clearly all
that thy words set forth and
explain;
and I pray therefore,
dear and gentle Father,
that thou expound love to me,
to which thou reduce every good
action and its opposite."
Whatever you have told me in
Canto XVII really is not enough.
And Virgil goes on explaining
the theory--that it's a very
philosophical theory,
that we have perceptions.
Your perception takes from
outward reality an impression
and unfolds it within you,
so it makes the mind turn to
it.
Whatever the will is bound,
that's really what we call
pleasure.
I'm paraphrasing poorly.
"Thy words and my
following..."
Excuse me, let me just mention
another little passage:
"Now may be plain,"
line 35,
"Now may be plain to thee
how hidden is the truth for
those who maintain that every
love is in itself
praiseworthy..."
He's attacking--this is the
view of the Epicureans who
believe that every pleasure,
without any particular judgment
attached to the object of
pleasure,
is praiseworthy.
Dante says no,
we have to exercise some moral
judgment.
We have to create distinctions.
We have to discriminate between
the good and the bad love.
"...
perhaps because its matter
always seems good,
but not every stamp is good,
even if it be good wax."
I would even go so far as to
say that he's really thinking
now of his friend Cavalcanti--
Guido's Epicurean--you saw him
mention in Canto XII by name--
Epicurean leanings.
The idea--that's the Epicurean
ethics, that if pleasure is
really the only object really
worthy of any pursuit and that's
really what we are doing.
When we are in pursuit of
knowledge or real experiences,
then they claim that all of
pleasure is good.
That's the hedonistic ethics
that Dante really renounces or
debates.
Then, in fact,
Virgil goes on saying:
"Thy words and my
following wit,"
this is Dante talking,
"have revealed the nature
of love to me,
but that has made me more full
of perplexity;
for if love is offered to us
from without and if the soul
moves with no other feet,
it has no merit when it goes
straight to crooked."
Now you say that everything is
love and the love that I have
depends on the experience of
images,
well in what--how am I going to
deserve for choosing well or not
choosing well,
since at the basis of the
imagination,
we have perceptions.
What I perceive may be looking
good to me and does not look
good to you,
so the issue is displaced from
the point of the world of
imagination to the world of
perception.
Virgil will go on explaining a
scholastic theory to the point
that indeed we incline to the
good,
but then actually we have
within us the faculty of choice.
He says, "In order that to
this will every other may be
conformed there is innate in you
the faculty which counsels and
which ought to hold the
threshold of assent."
He's talking about,
once again, free will and he
will add,
this is what I--this is on line
60 and following,
this is all I can tell you from
a philosophical point of view.
Other issues about the free
will will be explained to you by
Beatrice when she first comes to
you.
And so it would seem to make a
distinction between the
knowledge of Virgil and the
knowledge of Beatrice.
He said, "As far as reason
sees here I can tell thee,
beyond that;
wait only for Beatrice,
for it is a matter of
faith," and so on.
There seems to be two ways of
understanding this issue.
The fact is that Beatrice will
never discuss this problem,
but in a sense,
Beatrice represents the
explanation that Dante is
looking for,
because Beatrice is a kind of
love,
for Dante, that stands for a
visionary form of love,
and not just a love that can be
reduced to a question of
mechanics of physics of
perception.
That's really what Canto XVIII
seems to be doing then.
It responds,
enlarges, and at the same time
brings us back into the very
predicament that Canto XVII had
posed for us.
It seems that Dante is moving,
and at the same time,
an impasse--another impasse has
been reached.
Now, with this in mind,
we turn to what he unavoidably
has to do,
try to translate all of these
issues of love,
imagination,
choice, and from the
theoretical into the
autobiographical or existential
dimension.
This is done in the dream,
an erotic dream that Dante
relates at the beginning of
Canto XIX.
Before I turn to that canto,
I just want to tell you about
how Dante understand this.
He has one line at the very end
of Canto XVIII that I would--
the last line of Canto XVIII
--that I really want to
underline for you,
the whole paragraph reads:
"Then when the shades were
so far parted from us that they
could no longer be seen,
a new thought arose within me,
from which others many and
diverse were born;
and I rambled so from one to
the other, that in my wandering
my eyes closed and I changed my
musing into dream."
That introduces the dream of
Canto XIX,
but the line in Italian is
really very interesting because
it presents the connection
between thinking and dreaming.
He says, in fact the
translation: "My
musing,"
it's correct but it's really--
I would have said to make it
very clear,
my thought.
Dante says on line 145,
che li occhi per vaghezza
ricopersi, e 'l pensamento in
sogno trasmutai.
There's a kind of link,
a sort of sense of the
connection between thinking and
dreaming that Dante favors
dreaming at this point over
thinking.
You shouldn't be surprised that
Dante's doing this.
The Romance of the Rose,
a grand medieval epic,
is a dream, and tells the story
of a dream.
The Book of the
Duchess--Chaucer's The
Book of the Duchess,
is the story of a dream.
The Vita nuova is full
of dreams.
Even for those of you who are
interested in contemporary
literature,
fairly contemporary,
I'm thinking of Keats' great
poem,
"Sleep and Poetry."
I don't know how many of you
have had a chance to read that.
Poets love sleeping because
sleep introduces the idea of the
dream and the possibility of a
dream,
the possibility of a knowledge
which is not willed.
I finally have some revelations
within me which is not what I
would normally have if I were
awake,
so this is the great privilege
that they give to dreams.
Are the Middle Ages really
conscious of this dimension?
Yes, there is a text by an
author called Macrobius,
and if you want to know more
really,
which Macrobius,
who writes on The Dream of
Scipio,
Cicero's figure in the
Republic,
it's all about--it's an
encyclopedia of dreams and based
on Artemidorus,
but it's distinctions between
oracles,
fantasies, insomniac,
deliriums, dreams and so on.
They are very conscious of the
sort of power and revelations
that can come through dreams.
What is this dream about?
It's now definitely in the
world of acedia.
It's a dream--let me just read
this initial--the beginning of
Canto XIX.
I emphasize that this is now an
autobiographical--
the highlighting of the
autobiographical dimension of
all the problems we have been
discussing from XVII,
above all XVI, XVII, and XVIII.
Dante has to translate the
theories into a personal--
giving them a personal shape
and that to investigate the kind
of importance that they may have
for him.
It starts then with,
"In the hour when the
day's heat,
overcome by the earth and
sometimes by Saturn,
can no longer temper the cold
of the moon,
when the geomancers see their
Fortuna Major rise in the east
before dawn by a path which does
not long stay dark for it,
there came to me in dream a
woman stammering,
cross-eyed and crooked on her
feet with maimed hands and of
sallow hue.
I gazed at her,
and as the sun revives cold
limbs benumbed by the night,
so my look gave her a ready
tongue,
and then in a little time made
her quite erect and colored her
wan features as love desires.
When she had her speech thus
set free she began to sing so
that it would have been hard for
me to turn my mind from her.
'I am,' she sang,
'I am the sweet siren who
beguile the sailors in mid-sea,
so great delight it is to hear
me.
I turned Ulysses,
eager on his way,
to my song and he who dwells
with me rarely departs,
so wholly I content him.'
Her lips were not yet closed
again when a lady,
holy and alert,
appeared beside me to put her
to confusion.
'Oh Virgil, Virgil,
who is this?'
she said with anger.
And he came with his eyes fixed
on the honorable one;
he seized the other and laid
her bare in front,
tearing her clothes,
and showed me her belly.
That awoke me with the stench
that came from her.
I turned my eyes to the good
Master.
'Three times at least I have
called thee,' he said,
'rise and come,
let us find the opening by
which thou enterest."
That's the end of the dream,
the account of the dream,
and this is also--the journey
will continue that seemed to
have come to a halt here at
night.
As you recall,
just to give you a sense of
Dante's ordered poetic mind,
this is the second of three
dreams.
We didn't really read the first
one about--in Canto IX,
was the dream of Ganymede.
Dante's moving from the
anti-Purgatory to Purgatory
proper and then it's the--
the third one will appear in
Canto XXVII,
so that really Dante is
scanning these three dreams with
also a sense of numerical--
symbolic numerical precision
IX, XVIII,
retold in XIX,
but takes place during the
night and then XXVII.
This is the--it's a dream,
it's a dream that happens at
dawn,
just some details,
and a dream at dawn has always
the value they believed of it
being a kind of prophetic dream.
It's a dream that really has a
sort of a hue,
a color of the truth.
It says something about--so if
you understand the dream as an
allegory say,
because it's about a veil.
It's about tearing clothes.
There is something hidden
underneath it all,
then it may be this allegory
has a truth value.
It's not some kind of mere
fable or other.
Dante starts evoking the planet
Saturn which is--
we shall see that in--you know
that Dante mentions planets and
joins them to the various
liberal arts.
I probably have mentioned this
before.
So when we will be talking
about the moon,
Dante is going to discuss
grammar.
He'll talk about Mars,
the planet of war,
and there he'll talk about
music.
Jupiter and justice,
Saturn is astronomy,
also the planet of
contemplation.
In this sense,
I think that he's hinting that
sloth is the obverse side,
the parody of contemplation,
a different type of
self-absorption nonetheless.
Not a way of breaking out,
the contemplation means
breaking out of one's self and
reach some kind of--the gates
outside of time.
Here it's a dream that seems to
be--a movement,
an inward movement,
so it's Saturn.
Then he continues with this
language of astronomy and
divination who "no longer
temper the cold of the moon when
the geomancers see the Fortuna
Major."
This is a process of knowledge,
as divination.
That's a different type of
rational knowledge,
divining signs.
This is the context in which
the dream is set:
"rise in the east before
dawn by a path which does not
long stay dark for it,
there came to me in a
dream."
Now the dream starts.
The first thing that I have to
point out to you is that in
this--in the dream,
the dreamer is an object.
The dream comes to him.
Clearly, it is not willed,
it's not something that he
decides or he wants.
One is the object of some
dreams or apparitions,
or signs, images that descend
into one's self without one's
own self control or dominion
over there.
Dante seems to place himself in
a condition of passivity which
is the passivity of sloth.
The idea that I am awake and
therefore vigilant,
and therefore capable of making
judgments about what's happening
to me,
is here, now,
for the time being,
bracketed.
What is this dream about though?
Well it's a dream of a woman,
and the Italian text
plays--since this is a dream
about two women,
two modes of being,
two choices.
It's almost as if he were--he
isn't, but you know this is the
mythography of Hercules,
as they call him,
at the crossing road.
He had to choose between vice
and virtue,
but Hercules has an easy time
because he's always going to be
right: in thinking mythography,
if you go to the right then you
really have--
by going toward virtue,
left and right,
being dexterous rather than
sinister,
the idea of the left being bad.
Here we don't have that,
here's two women,
but the language of the poem
distinguishes very carefully
between them.
One is a femmina,
there is materiality and even a
kind of animal sense of the
word,
and when the other woman
appears, she's called a
donna;
donna is the Italian
word from domina,
the lady is called a holy lady,
I guess, "lady holy and
alert," etc.
She is--this woman,
she crystallizes what we would
call the aesthetics of the ugly.
We're always talking about the
beauty and the idea that beauty
brings about a kind of
revelation of love and the
pleasure that goes with beauty.
In fact, one can say that
love--no?--this is a Platonic
way of understanding love has
always a hunger for beauty.
The conventional way of
thinking about aesthetics is to
imagine beautiful proportionate
forms.
Here, Dante is giving exactly
the opposite,
an aesthetic of the ugly.
But an ugly which is not static
and somehow is--experiences
metamorphosis.
In fact, look what happens,
she is "stammering,
cross-eyed, and crooked on her
feet," she is the
anti-Beatrice by--
obviously, "with maimed
hands and sallow hue."
Now he changes:
from the dreamer as an object,
the dreamer becomes a subject,
"I."
You see that,
from "..
.came to me..."
and then, "I gazed at her,
and as the soul revives cold
limbs benumbed by the night,
so my look..."
His desires transform this
image, and from the ugly image
that it was,
it becomes now instead invested
with attributes of
attractiveness and "colored
her wan features as love
desires,"
as love prompts.
Then this is what--we still
don't understand who she is.
"When she had her speech
thus set free,
she began to sing so that it
would have been hard for me to
turn my mind from her."
The first temptation that we
know that--the vehicle of the
temptation--is the song.
This is also,
and primarily,
a poetic temptation.
A certain way of understanding
poetry, a kind of even
meretricious form of poetry.
What does she say?
She brings to center stage the
myth of Ulysses,
which is by now as you know,
is the steady temptation for
Dante.
It's the point of reference:
to what extent is my own
journey that I believe is taking
place under the aegis of divine
providence,
to what extent is it a form of
transgression?
A way of going beyond
boundaries, of breaking down all
limits, because after all that's
what Ulysses did in Canto XXVI.
And Dante knows where he has
placed him, but he cannot get
him out of his mind because
Ulysses stands for something
powerful.
What he stands for is the idea
that there is no knowledge worth
having which is not connected
with transgressions,
which is not connected with
breaking down all barriers and
limitations.
In a way, because Dante doesn't
do these things accidentally,
when he comes to Canto XXVI of
Paradise,
he will see Adam,
and there is another who is for
him,
without a doubt,
a poet, because he's the name
giver.
He is the name giver of the
world.
He is the one who brings the
world into being through
language.
And when Dante meets Adam,
there will be some interesting
details that we can talk about
there,
but I can anticipate this for
you: Adam is the one who had
understood transgression and
that transgression though,
for Adam, appears as a sort of
growth.
It's not a fall,
for Dante, it's a growth.
It's a growth and understanding
other types of limitations
because we cannot just say that
we tear down all limits;
we tear down some limits in our
experience.
Adam tears down and eats of the
fruit of the tree that had been
forbidden for him,
like a good son.
The Father says,
don't eat it and he goes and
eats it, and thence he eats it,
he grows into a human being.
He discovers that the world is
not for him to be as a child,
that he has to have other
experiences of death,
of maturity,
of work, etc.
There are ways in which we have
to understand this idea of
breaking limits in a different
way from maybe the way I may
have conveyed it to you.
In other words,
Dante, here,
is thinking of Ulysses and
anticipates the story of Adam.
The great temptation for Dante
is to believe that he too--his
journey is a journey that
reenacts Ulysses' journey.
The siren--that's what she's
telling him--what she's telling
him is, 'I made Ulysses happy.'
It's a lie, because we do know
that Ulysses never really
stopped off the island of Capri
in whose Grotto where the siren,
is mythologically said to
reside.
We do know that he did listen
to the song of the siren;
he made sure that his
companions would not,
and he had himself bound.
Here it is again,
bound to the mast of the ship.
There is a transgression and a
binding going on at the same
time.
As I said--at any rate,
she lies about,
"I turned Ulysses,
eager on his way to my song,
and he who dwells with
me," so the first--
the other lie or the extension
of the lie is that the siren is
making false promises of
happiness to the dreamer.
What she's saying is,
you stay here with me and I am
the end of all that you desire.
I am going to give you all the
pleasures that you want,
and therefore,
your journey may very well be
over.
If you are weary of the road,
this is the place where you
should stop.
We have another figure that
emerges.
Clearly, the antagonist of the
siren,
we don't know who she is,
we'll find out very quickly in
Canto XXX and XXXI,
because the same scene will be
re-enacted with the arrival of
Beatrice.
We imagine that here too,
we have force to imagine,
that here too she is Beatrice.
"Her lips were not yet
closed again when a lady holy
and alert,"
a woman in the sense of not
femmina,
"appeared beside me to put
her to confusion.
'O Virgil, Virgil,
who is this?' she said with
anger" and he came with
her.
What is the difference between
them, between these two women?
They are two different forms of
poetry.
Now we understand why Dante had
to be talking about the
imagination all along,
because this is really what
will introduce him to the stakes
in claiming to be a poet.
This is what he's been talking
about--
the actual faculty of himself
as a poet,
and the cantos that will come,
XXI, XXII to XXVI and XXVII
constitute the most important
segment about ways of
understanding literary history,
literary tradition,
or the place of originality
within that particular history
and so on.
We are going to enter the world
of poetry more directly.
So they are two different women;
they speak two different voices.
One sweet, meretricious and
false, but a sweet song;
the other one very harsh,
who says the journey is not
over.
One forecloses the journey
of--and the quest of Dante.
Be like Ulysses,
I know that you want to be like
Ulysses, you can stay here with
me, and I am the end of all your
journeys and your quests.
The other one is claiming
exactly the opposite.
The journey has to continue.
These two types of songs,
the song of the siren is sweet,
which has also the stench of
death attached to it.
The stench of the decomposition
of her body,
and on the other hand,
a journey by this austere
voice,
the voice of--maybe the voice
of love,
the voice of harshness,
just the language of sweetness
is that of love as an ongoing
quest.
That's what she's saying.
Two forms of love,
two forms of poetry,
two types of women.
The scene, in case you are
interested in this--as many of
you I'm sure have thought about
it--literally are stages.
The scene at the beginning of
The Consolation of
Philosophy of Boethius,
which in turn is thinking about
the Book X of the
Republic by Plato:
the idea of the place of love
and the place of poetry and
philosophy.
Dante changes that tradition.
This is not just poetry versus
philosophy;
it's two different types of
poetry.
Poetry can be also a
philosophical poetry.
Poetry can be meretricious and
poetry can be also the sort of
rigorous, severe form of
investigation of oneself in the
world.
Two different types of poetry,
two different types of loves,
two different types of women.
Which of the two is better?
How can we go on deciding that
one is better than the other?
Is there an objective pattern,
an objective criterion,
by which we can say Beatrice,
is actually better than the
siren?
Does Dante--is Dante aware of
this idea of--yes,
and the reason is going to be
the following,
very simple:
the avoidance of death.
The siren is the figure that
stands for death.
Underneath the pleasures of her
language, there is a stench that
emanates from underneath that
allegory.
Dante sees the danger of
closing and the danger of making
the here and now,
and the limitations of the here
and now,
and the limitations of that
song the end of his journey.
It's really a choice between an
open-ended quest and the
foreclosure of the siren.
This is the only way in which
you can objectively believe that
there is a hierarchy between
these two loves and between
these two women.
We move to Canto XXI and XXII,
but I'm wondering if I
shouldn't take a few questions
here about this canto,
or any other problems,
before we move onto something a
little bit more--
a little bit different,
more classical:
the encounter between Statius
and Virgil.
Let me see if there are some
questions now about this phase,
these cantos,
or would you like to--me to go
on and then maybe we can come
back to them?
Student:  Are we
supposed to draw a connection
between Casella and
anti-Purgatory?
Prof: Very good.
Say again?
Student:  Are we
supposed to draw a connection
between Casella and the siren?
Prof: The question is
excellent.
Are we supposed to draw some
connection between this scene
and the scene of Casella in
Canto II, above all of
Purgatory?
I call it excellent,
because I agree you are
supposed to--and it's the
reappearance under different
guises of the same temptation.
How the aesthetic can become
both a way of gathering people
around itself.
That's the famous story of
Casella,
the power of the song just
collects,
gathers, but at the same time
it induces us all to
forgetfulness of whatever
purposes those souls are
supposed to entertain and carry
out.
The difference of course is
that it's the same story here
now, the difference is not
between, let's say,
Casella and others with the
language of Cato.
Here it's more an
autobio--directly,
we are moved into the
consciousness of the pilgrim.
We have entered this--as deep
as we can into his unconscious
mind.
This is the moment of what--he
comes to an amazing
self-revelation.
The story of Casella had the
ring of a public discourse:
poetry as a public act,
gathering a number of people
around it.
So this is very good.
That's--thank you for
mentioning that.
By the way, I don't know that
I--we never probably read it,
but if you read the beginning,
I think I read it in Italian
for Professor Brooks as I know
she likes the Provenal
song,
but the beginning of Canto
XVIII also that moment of the
nostalgia for the safety of
home,
the weariness of--the evening
song, etc.
That represents another version
of the same kind of dilemma with
which the pilgrim is confronted.
Okay, we can come back to some
of this.
We move into this segment of
the poem: XXI,
XXII going through XXIII,
XXIV, which really has poetry
now as the subject matter.
Dante begins with,
let's say, the classical
tradition.
The relationship between an
encounter that takes place,
wherein they,
in the world of avarice and
prodigality,
the encounter between Statius
and Virgil.
As you know Statius views
himself as a disciple of Virgil,
and in many ways he challenges
Virgil's ideology,
Virgil's thought.
Whereas Virgil can go on
writing a poem,
the Aeneid and the
Eclogues,
which are about the pastoral
world,
or the Georgics,
this world about the
cultivation of the earth,
where Virgil appears at his
most anti-Orphic.
He distinguishes and distances
himself from the traditional of
Orpheus,
the poet of mad love who
descends into the depths of
Hades and,
of course, is waylaid by the
mad love for Eurydices--
the way of conquering death
through the song.
He believes that through--by
singing he can bend the laws of
death and therefore gain
immortality.
Virgil opposes the world of
work, the world of mature--
the responsible world of
Aeneas, the hero who is so
divided against himself,
and yet manages to always find
his way around in this kind of
wriggly,
erratic path of his epic.
Statius counters Virgil.
Statius writes the
Thebaid, he writes another--
which he never
finishes--another little epic,
called the Achilleid,
a story about Achilles,
but it's only a fragment.
He writes the Thebaid,
which really goes against those
claims of Virgil.
He retrieves--makes a
conjunction between tragedy and
the epic,
the world of Jocasta and
Oedipus, the monstrosity of that
world,
the world of Polyneices and the
Eteocles,
the world of Antigone,
cast as a kind of nightmarish
world.
It's literally the most
psychological of these epics,
the wars that happen in the
mind, and this idea of
monstrosity of human fate and
human desires.
These are the two worlds that
Dante now wants to bring
together in this little
epyllion, I would call it.
"Epyllion"
is a Greek word meaning a
'little epic,' that is to say,
a transcription of two epic
texts gathered into one,
into a lyrical form.
He has a tough task because
what he wants to show is the
possibility of harmonizing the
two of them and he shows how the
two of them really talk as
friends,
friends across time of course.
Statius lives around the year
70 A.D., Virgil dies in the year
19.
And now they are friends
because poetry has managed--
their poetry has made them--the
poetry of Virgil has made them
friends and Statius is a sort of
classical version of Dante
himself.
Dante is the disciple of Virgil
and so was Statius,
so he has to bring them
together.
But it's not a question of
making them agree,
only because they had two
different visions,
that in and of itself may not
be all that difficult.
Statius is very skeptical about
the Empire, Virgil is not all
that skeptical.
It's possible to read the
Aeneid and see that there
is a lot of ambiguity in the way
in which he talks about Augustus
and the Empire,
but he's basically writing the
epic that justifies the ideology
of the Empire.
The real difficulty between
them is that Dante is--
the real difficulty and
challenge for Dante--
is that he has to try to
understand how Statius has
tried--
to adjust Statius' vision of
monstrosity to some of idea of
the sacred.
This is the real challenge.
This is the difference that
Dante has from the classical
world.
How do we understand the sacred?
In what way is it possible to
use Statius, Virgil,
as he already did with Cato,
who is by the way the hero of
Lucan;
a third poet of this epic
tradition, Virgil,
Lucan, Statius--is it possible
to see in these texts of Statius
the seeds of something good?
How can we build anything good
out of this vision of heroes and
characters who fornicate with
their own fantasies?
Who cannot really get out of
their minds, who just
are--discover their own
unchanging submission to a force
that transcends them to fate.
It's really absolutely a
different world view from the
world of Virgil.
Let me just go on a little bit
with XXI,
I'll just start talking first
of all with--
Dante begins with an allusion
to this natural thirst,
which is this world of--the
natural thirst for knowledge.
It's really much the world of
the Banquet,
the world of Aristotle.
We have this incredible thirst
for knowledge and then this
figure called Statius appears.
We are also being told here
that nature, the natural world
is mysteriously shaking.
There's an earthquake,
because every time that a soul
gets liberated from the
purgatorial experience of
expiation,
this purification and
expiation, then the mountain
trembles and Statius can go on
with them up to the Garden of
Eden and then Statius reveals
himself and he will say around
line 60,
"And I,
who have lain in this pain five
hundred years and more,"
Statius speaking,
"felt but now my will free
for a better threshold,
therefore thou didst feel the
earthquake and hear the devout
spirits through the mountain
render praises to the Lord--
soon."
The resurrection has taken
place.
This is going to be the
resurrection of Statius and
Virgil.
It's Statius,
but also Virgil,
and their own vision.
So he goes on describing
himself, "In the time when
the good Titus,
the emperor,"
he's evoking the time of the--
he's recalling the time of the
destruction of the temple in
Jerusalem at a time when the
good Titus,
"by help with the King
most high avenged,"
means justice,
divine, the mysteries of
justice, "the wounds from
which pour the blood sold by
Judas,' replied the spirit,
'I bore yonder the name that
most endures and honors most,
famous indeed,
but still without faith."
Statius a pagan,
really born again,
this is the born again pagan
that appears in this canto.
"So sweet was my spirit of
song that Rome drew me,"
it's an interesting image.
It's really speaking of Rome
having a kind of power that
usually will lead with love,
with desire,
the pull of desire.
Rome brought him to it,
to herself, "a Toulousan,
to itself and there I was
worthy to have my brows adorned
with myrtle.
Men yonder still speak my name,
which is Statius;
and I sang of Thebes and then
of great Achilles,
but fell by the way with the
second burden."
He could never complete the
second text.
Now look at the way he speaks
about poetry;
he speaks through sparks,
as a kind of fire.
"The sparks that kindled
the fire in me were from the
divine flame,
the divine flame from which
more than a thousand have been
lit--
I mean the Aeneid"--
That's already--poetry now is
invested with power.
The power to light the fire in
the readers and in its
followers, "which was in
poetry my mother and my nurse;
without it I had not weighed a
drachm and to have lived yonder,
when Virgil lived I would have
contented to a sun more than I
was due before coming forth from
banishment."
There are two metaphors to
speak of poetry,
one is that of the sparks of
fire, and the second one is that
of nourishing the inner hunger,
mother and nurse.
It's nursing--the nursing of
its readers so a great
acknowledgement of a master,
without his knowledge that it
is Virgil to whom he is
speaking.
And then Canto XXI which is
another image that may remind
you of the story of Casella.
Statius reveals--Dante reveals
Statius identity,
Virgil's identity to Statius,
and they try to--
the two of them try to
embrace--"Already he was
bending to embrace,"
lines 130 and following,
"my Teacher's feet;
but he said to him,
'Brother do not so,
for thou art a shade and a
shade thou seest.'
And he rising:
'Now thou canst understand the
measure of the love that burns
in me for thee,
when I forget our emptiness and
treat shades as solid
things."
A mistake that has been made
before and a mistake that I
think is meant to convey the
claims or the illusions of poets
to believe that there is some
kind of solidity to them,
and not just to their poetry,
to their works,
but a solidity to them that
this embrace belies.
There's no solidity to them.
There is a kind of emptiness.
There's a sort of distance
between the poets and their
works.
This is not going to,
I think, interfere very much
because it's the works,
the works of art that we are
going to be talking about in
Canto XXII.
The two poets now are
self--each in acknowledgement of
the other and they go on talking
about line 10 and following,
Virgil asks Statius to explain
to him why this moral blight
existed in him,
why this sin of avarice,
and he says--
this is the passage:
"Love,"
Canto XXII,
lines 12 and following,
"Love kindled by virtue
always kindles another"--
That's the sort of vitality and
power of love.
It's not self-enclosed;
it's one that goes on creating
and propagating itself.
It has a generosity of its own.
It has a kind of charitableness
of it's,
"if only its flame appear
without"--
So fire and love seem to be
conjoined by this common
element,
the common element of the power
of propagation or
self-perpetuation.
"From the hour, therefore,
when Juvenal descended among us
in the LImbo of Hell and made
thy affection known to me my
goodwill toward thee was as
great as ever held anyone for a
person not seen,
so that now these stairs will
seem short to me.
But tell me,
and as a friend,
forgive me with too much
assurance I slacken the rein,
and as a friend speak with me
know--
how could avarice find a place
in thy breast along with so much
wisdom as by thy zeal thou wast
filled with?"
This is a passage of some
importance.
Because, first of all,
the claim of friendship between
Virgil--he's moved by the show
of friendship on the part of
Statius.
Let's talk now as friends.
Friendship is an ethical virtue
as you know,
in Aristotle's Ethics
and for Cicero,
who writes a treatise called
On Friendship,
which Dante mentions at the
beginning of his philosophical
text,
in the belief that friendship
is really the other language the
other term for philosophy.
It's the friend and the
philosopher that are
interchangeable because there is
a love--in friendship,
there is a love of truth that
is the idea.
There is some exaggeration on
the part of Virgil because there
is really--a friendship implies
some kind--some degree of
equality.
You must have--in order to be
friends you must have some idea,
because in fact it's usually
said that tyrants and slaves are
not capable of love or
friendship,
because both--since one is the
inversion of the other--
both really have a kind of
inequality vis--vis the
other.
The slave is,
by definition inferior,
the tyrant thinks that he's
superior so friendship demands
that kind if equality.
This is a little bit of
exaggeration because there is no
equality between Statius.
It's a rhetorical exaggeration
of Statius and Virgil.
Virgil is--acknowledges being
superior to Statius.
Statius sees himself as a
disciple and therefore views
Virgil as superior from a poetic
point of view;
from a theological point of
view Statius is superior to
Virgil.
Statius is going on to
Paradise and Virgil is
going to go back Limbo.
So there is a kind of the push
in the direction of wishful
thinking maybe on the part of
Virgil.
I must also add that Dante has
a kind of--
some work also to do about--he
may be aware that friendship was
never really thought of as a
Christian virtue.
It's a classical and pagan
virtue, and because it really
confuses--it's the idea a friend
is always part of one's soul.
It's really earthbound.
It's an earthbound experience,
so it was always the
thought--not Augustine.
Augustine who has a friend
Alypius and feels responsible
for Alypius,
but by and large--it was this
idea that the friendship could
distract the mind from an ascent
to higher and superior ends,
paradisiac ecstasies and
pleasures.
Dante has to be aware that
there were efforts to
Christianize this idea.
Nonetheless,
it brings the conversation
between them back to the earth
and they talk as if they were
two friends really meeting in
the forum,
in the agora,
and chatting about their moral
failings or their own poetic
crafts and visions.
How could you find--how could
you be so avaricious,
when you are so enlightened in
so many other ways?
That's the question.
Statius responds that he's not
avaricious and I think that that
adds a great deal about their
understandings--
the misunderstandings of each
other--
but also their understandings
of poetry.
He goes on talking about the
fact that he is prodigal all the
time.
So that is to say that he--you
may remember from Canto VII of
Inferno,
the difference between the
avaricious and the sins of
prodigality.
Prodigality was a violation of
the economy of goods by
devaluing, by getting
rid--devaluing them,
not holding onto them.
The avaricious overvalues the
goods and tries to heap--
amass larger quantities of
goods, so he goes on really
thinking--
Statius wants to make it clear
for at least 40 lines about the
fact that he's--
he was prodigal and we have to
understand why he would say
that.
Then in fact he goes on
acknowledging,
once again, Statius,
for his moral conversion.
So that's the first thing about
what poetry can do.
"Know then that avarice
was too far removed from me,
and this excess thousands of
moons have punished.
And had it not been that I
corrected my ways when I
understood the lines,
where as if enraged at human
nature,
thou didst cry: "To what,
O cursed hunger for gold,
dost thou not drive the
appetite of mortals?'
I should be rolling the weights
and know the dismal
jousts."
What he's saying is that he
read a passage in Book III of
the Aeneid,
the story that we already saw
of Polydorus,
who had been killed because
of--they want to rob him of his
gold and Statius reached a moral
conversion.
There's a lot we can say about
these lines.
First of all,
I think this exemplifies how we
actually read and we dismember
the integrity of the text.
We take out of a book,
out of a passage,
that which we find relevant to
us and he takes some lines,
and not only takes some lines
from the Book III of the
Aeneid,
he also alters their meaning.
The original text of Virgil's
is exactly the opposite to
what--why do you not contain the
appetite of mortals or sacred
hunger for gold?
Which the text translates as
'cursed'--
because the word sacred,
which Dante is using here,
why do you not contain,
"O sacred fame of
gold" O sacra fame
dell'oro.
The word "sacred,"
as you probably know,
some of you may know,
means two things.
It's the most ambiguous term
that you--
semantically speaking--because
it can describe both that which
we call the holy,
and that which we call the
profane.
It joins them together:
there's no clear-cut
distinction between the
profanation or blasphemy,
on the other hand,
or the sense of holiness.
I can understand why my
translation, Sinclair,
my translator,
decides to choose the 'cursed'
instead of call it 'sacred,' for
it's the curse.
He's dismembering,
he is taking one side
over--there's a much more
complicated version of the
meaning of the word.
So that's one thing,
but the poetic text of Virgil
has a moral power over and
against Virgil's own intentions.
We can understand now
retrospectively why Dante has to
distinguish between poets and
their works.
We can read the works
regardless of the intentions of
the authors and we can select or
take out of those texts whatever
we think that we--
however we think that they
speak to us and then he goes on
describing his poetic growth.
"Now," lines 55,
"Now, when thou did sing
the cruel arms of the double woe
of Jocasta,"
the double woe is the two
children,
Eteocles and Polyneices,
in the tragic and epic text
called the Thebaid,
"said the singer of the
Bucolics."
That's already the opposition.
Virgil now appears as the
author of a pastoral poem,
the Bucolics,
where rivalries are always
going to be placated.
The Bucolics of--the
pastoral poems of Virgil are
always about rivalry.
A rivalry between two
shepherds: which of us they ask,
is the better singer?
Which of us is the better poet?
That is always--there's never
any tragic outcome.
There's some uneasiness,
some anxiety between in--
running through that kind of
debate between the poets,
but it's not the rivalry of
Polyneices and Eteocles.
That's really the difference
that Dante is highlighting
between them.
And then it continues, "...
it does not appear by the notes
which Clio touches with
thee," the Bucolics,
and on other hand Clio is the
muse of history.
So Clio is the muse for
history, the world of Statius,
"that the faith yet made
thee faithful without which
well-doing is not enough.
If that is so,
what sun or what candles
dispelled thy darkness,
so that thereafter thou didst
lift the sails behind the
fisherman?"
Now we know that what he's
really asking,
in a general way,
is the relationship between
poetry and faith.
How could Statius--we know how
he reached this moral
conversion, now we have to be
told somehow,
how did he go on finding faith?
What is the relationship
between the two of them?
Can poetry reveal and lead us
onto the world of faith or not?
Statius has already--that's
really the answer that he will
provide: "And the other
answered him,
'Thou first directed me to
Parnassus,"
the mountain of poetry.
The poetic experience,
the poetic apprenticeship,
is the preamble to the
experience of faith--
"to drink in its
caves"--
a metaphor that picks up the
natural thirst of the previous
canto,
"to drink in its caves
and,
first, after God enlightens me.
Thou didst like him that goes
by night and carries the light
behind him and does not help
himself but makes wise those
that follow when thou
saidst."
In a moment we will see he
said, but the metaphor is that
of really--
Virgil is a prophetic voice who
speaks,
but that language he uses like
the--
a lamp that he carries on his
back for the benefit of those
who follow,
and himself clearly remains in
the dark.
That's what he said.
"The age turns new again;
justice comes back and the
primal years of men,
and a new race descends from
heaven."
This is the famous fourth
eclogue of Virgil,
where Virgil is celebrating the
birth of a child,
Pollio, and around this birth
of a child,
he is also talking about the
rejuvenation of the world.
It's an emblem,
Pollio's birth is an emblem for
this Pythagorean vision that he
has,
a vision whereby the world goes
through 360,000 years of the
Golden Age,
the Silver Age,
and so on, and then degrades
itself and goes right back to
where it started.
A Pythagorean vision of
metamorphosis and circulation of
the universe.
It's the fourth eclogue.
Interestingly,
this also crystallizes that
which is the fundamental issue
of Virgil's vision.
The concern with birth,
the concern with the fact of
being born,
that the fact of being born has
within itself the potential to
renew the world,
to effect the world and change
the direction of the world.
And then we know that he will
say,
and I will stop here,
because we are coming to the
end of the period:
"Through thee I was a
poet,
through thee Christian;
but that thou mayst see better
what I outline,
I shall set my hand to color
it.
Already the world was
everywhere big,"
pregnant the Italian says,
"with the true faith sown
by the messengers...
" and so on.
He's going to talk how the
world outside,
only buttressed and reinforced
the message of faith that he had
found in the fourth eclogue.
The fourth eclogue is seen as a
messianic eclogue,
but that line that makes the
transition from poetry to faith,
"I was a poet through
thee,
I was a poet,
through thee a Christian,"
I think really makes it
necessary for us to linger on it
for a little bit.
First of all the line has what
we call an anaphora,
"Through thee I was a
poet, I was a poet through thee
Christian."
This is the same line that
says, per te,
the Italian word line 73,
per te poeta fui,
per te cristiano.
The anaphora gives continuity
to the movement of the line from
poetry to faith,
per te..
.per te.
Nonetheless,
if you read this line carefully
in Italian you see that there is
also a caesura.
You know what I mean by caesura?
Falling in the middle,
a break, per te,
break, per te cristiano.
The lines--gives a--has a
mobility that seems to promise
the transition from poetry to
faith,
but at the same time
technically, it forces you to
stop as if there were two
discontinuous experiences.
You cannot quite go from one
world of poetry to the one world
of faith.
You can go from one world of
poetry to one world of faith.
That ambiguity of poetry is
exactly what they are trying to
retrieve.
What did I say here today about
this issue of Statius and
Virgil?
Statius is dealing with the
tragedy of birth.
Virgil deals with,
optimistically,
about the history-making
quality of the event of birth.
That is, at the same time,
a desire to establish a sense
of what is the sacred?
I will try to discuss with you,
later,
how poetry is now invested with
the kind of sacredness,
the ambiguous sense of the word
about the profane and the holy
within it.
It's a hybrid,
and it's this hybrid that will
allow Dante to assimilate
Statius' vision to his own
understanding of history and the
sacred.
Let me stop here and see if
there are questions.
Please.
Student:  It seems like
it's more common for Dante to be
the one to ask the people they
meet for their stories.
Is this the only place that
Virgil is the one who asks the
questions or what is the
specific event here?
Prof: Virgil is the--
the question is,
it seems that usually it's
Dante who interviews the people
he meets and--
but here in Canto XXI and XXII,
it's Virgil and is that the
case,
and if it's true why would that
be the case?
The answer is that that's not
really true because in the canto
of Ulysses, it is he who--it is
Virgil who speaks,
you remember,
to Ulysses.
It's Virgil--so it's Virgil and
Ulysses.
It really has more to do with
the figures of the classical
world that seem to be,
in this case,
Virgil seems to be best
indicated for Statius as he was
for Virgil.
Since you are interested in
this aspect of the dramatization
of the poem,
I could mention to you for
instance there are cantos in
Inferno,
we didn't have a chance to talk
about them where the--
Virgil would completely
abandon--Dante says,
well you go here,
I don't want to be with you,
you go and on your own carry
out this introduction without--
I'll wait for you here.
That happens,
for instance,
in the canto of fraud and
usury.
It is as if Dante had something
to better understand on his own
without Virgil's presence,
but usually that is the way in
which the style of the
representation takes place,
who is most apt in the case of
the classical figures,
the classical poet speaking for
a classical character.
Student:  I wondered if
you could comment a little
further on the significance in
Canto XIX of what looks like a
kind of re-enactment of the Fall
of Adam and Eve.
It's almost as if this woman
even in the--
Prof: In the dream.
Student:  The
siren--yes, in the dream,
when she brings forth this
promise of happiness,
it's really echoing the promise
of Lucifer of this,
I will make you like God.
Why is this sort of--why is
this theme of sort of the Adam
theme coming up here in XIX and
is there some sort of strand
that I'm missing?
Prof: The--
well--the question is that it
says in Canto XIX,
in the dream of the siren,
there is an echo of the Fall of
Adam more than Lucifer,
I would say, the Fall of Adam.
Why would there be that--if
that's true why would there be
that echo?
My answer is, I didn't catch it.
I never caught this echo of
Adam there.
It's actually the story of the
temptation of this woman fish,
that's what she is,
right?
The siren who wants to induce
forgetfulness in the pilgrim;
it's really a classical figure.
I would say that--I sort of
resist the--hearing here the
figure of--in the figure of Adam
because Adam doesn't really talk
about falling.
This is a danger for the
pilgrim who--
he's dramatizing his sense of
yielding,
surrendering his will to the
seduction,
the seductive song of the siren.
Adam with--this is a story of
love.
With Adam, the story becomes
one of knowledge;
it's a little bit different.
There may be echoes,
I'm not going to be so firm and
say no, there is no echo of that
but I didn't catch it.
I didn't feel the necessity for
that, actually,
for my argument.
Student:  Okay,
then maybe I'm answering my own
question here,
but wouldn't you say that the
theme of knowledge and
transgression runs through both
the dream sequence that Dante
has and the story of Adam's
Fall?
I mean, is there that theme
where Ulysses wanted to sort of
gain this knowledge,
this experience of hearing the
siren's song,
right and to gain that
knowledge he had to sort of
transgress.
Isn't that what the siren
represents?
You say he keeps coming back to
this theme of Ulysses--
Prof: He does.
He mentions the story of
Ulysses.
He does mention the story of
Student:  Is that where
the Adam connection really comes
in?
Because Adam's--ultimately ate
the fruit for knowledge.
Prof: Yeah,
well I indicated that the story
of Adam in Canto XXVI
retrospectively illuminates
what's happening in Canto XXVI
of Inferno and that he
too experienced--
understands knowledge and
transgression,
that they go hand in hand,
and that it's difficult--
impossible to separate them and
that's the story of Ulysses.
Dante does feel that he's--but
it's a dangerous temptation for
him to believe that he's like
Ulysses.
Whereas, he has no problem
later in--when he understands
what the story of Adam is,
in thinking,
in acknowledging that Adam is
the arch poet.
We are all reinventing the
world, etc.
So I would say that there are
three figures here:
Ulysses,
Adam, and Dante and--but the
relation between them is never
what one of--
full of identification on the
part of Dante with either--
he comes here approximates them
and somehow also pulls away from
both.
He's not really Adam.
He's not the arch poet who
names the world,
and he's not really Ulysses.
That fear that he may be like
Ulysses, which is a more
dangerous sense that he has,
that will continue more openly
as he goes on.
The story of Adam is going to
be picked up in the Garden of
Eden.
The Garden of Eden,
of course, that is the idea
that we lost a garden but Dante
does not want to be in that
garden anyway.
When he comes to the Garden of
Eden, he identifies it with a
lot of things,
really nostalgia for the
mother.
He doesn't--he understands that
he has to grow up;
he has to get out of that
fantasy.
I don't know if this is--
Student:  What confuses
me I guess is that the siren
here in the dream sequence seems
to be wanting to halt Dante's
quest,
his journey forward for
knowledge.
Prof: Yes, absolutely.
Student:  Yet,
with respect to Ulysses,
the siren seemed to represent
the opposite,
in the sense that his
interaction with her was
something where he was trying to
go past the bounds to gain
knowledge or gain experience of
hearing her.
I'm trying to draw the
connections in my mind for what
is really Dante trying to tell
us with this sequence?
Why does he go back to this
reference to the siren?
I mean maybe you could just
summarize;
I guess maybe it would just
help clear it up what she
represents to Dante here in
Canto XIX versus what she
represents to Ulysses?
Prof: Good,
what does the siren represent?
Very briefly,
what does the siren represent
to Dante and to Ulysses?
What is the difference?
To Dante, the siren represents
the lure of death.
He understands that beneath
that promises of yield to the
here and now and to my voice
there is really--
there's a nothingness and he's
attracted to that nothingness.
That's really what it is.
For Ulysses,
she also represents the
extraordinary enchantment of the
song that would lead him to
death because that's what
happens to all those who listen
to the siren.
Ulysses wants to hear it and
bind himself so that does not
yield altogether to her call.
That's how I can put it.
Thank you. We'll see you.